WASHINGTON WITH MORE.
>> GOOD MORNING, ED.
MARCO RUBIO IS NOT THE ONLY ONE
HERE.
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE ARE
STARTING TO RING ALARM BELLS
ABOUT THE THREAT OF THIS DRUG
SHORTAGE HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
SOURCES TELL ME THAT AS CHINA IS
TAMPING DOWN ON THE SPREAD, THIS
OTHER NEW THREAT IS NOW JUST
BEGINNING TO RAMP UP.
FOX WAS TOLD BY SENATOR RUBIO
THAT ABOUT 80% OF THE
INGREDIENTS IN DRUGS HERE ARE
MADE ABROAD.
MOST OF THAT 80% IS COMING FROM
CHINA.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> NOW, WE DON’T NOW -- THERE
WILL BE SHORTAGES.
I ANTICIPATE THAT THERE WILL BE
BECAUSE THOSE FACTORIES HAVE
BEEN SHUT DOWN BECAUSE OF THE
VIRUS.
>> THIS WORRY DOESN’T GO ALL THE
WAY TO THE TOP.
EVEN PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE
BROUGHT THIS ISSUE UP.
HE DID IT WITH PHARMACEUTICAL
EXECS OVER AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE SAID HIS MAIN GOAL HERE IS TO
BRING MANUFACTURING BACK TO
AMERICA.
HE SAID IF THAT HAPPENS, WE CAN
BE MUCH MORE SELF-RELIANT GOING
FORWARD.
PHARMACEUTICAL EXECS AGREE WITH
HIM.
THE CEO TOLD ME LAST WEEKEND THE
VAST MAJORITY OF DRUG
INGREDIENTS TODAY ARE MADE
EITHER IN CHINA OR IN INDIA.
HE SAID IT IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE.
HERE IS THE RUB, THOUGH PURE
CHINA, RATHER THAN TRYING TO
CALM FEARS NOW, AS RATCHETING UP
THREATS.
THIS RECENT ARTICLE CAME OUT IN
CHINA STATE-RUN NEWSPAPER.
IT IS BASICALLY THE MOUTHPIECE
FOR THE COMMUNIST PARTY.
IT HAS CLAIMED THAT CHINESE
MIGHT IMPOSE CONTROL THAT WOULD
PLUNGE AMERICA INTO "THE MIGHTY
SEA OF THE CORONAVIRUS."
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THIS
ISN’T REALLY A HYPOTHETICAL
THREAT.
THE FDA HAS ALREADY ANNOUNCED A
DRUG SHORTAGE RELATED TO THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THEY HAVEN’T SAID WHICH DRUGS
THIS IS, PERHAPS TO QUELL FEARS
AND INSIGHT SOME KIND OF A PANIC